[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
una de esas crisis derivadas de la
guerra en ucrania la crisis de alimentos
que repercute ya en varias zonas del
mundo para ello nos acompañan en este
estudio sabin grande a lampe periodista
independiente especializada en
latinoamérica bienvenidas a luís buenos
días jon cerezo y responsable de campaña
humanitaria de oxfam bienvenido jon
muchas gracias buenos días y nos
acompaña también en tu pellets a
distancia a jean-pierre de solanes
investigador en ciencias económicas y
experto en medio ambiente de la
universidad parís este bienvenido buenas
tardes gracias por invitación la crisis
de alimentos derivada de la guerra de
ucrania hoy nuestro asunto en primera
plana
bueno la guerra de un ucrania golpeado a
los mercados energéticos del mundo ahora
el planeta afronta y enfrenta una crisis
más profunda la escasez de alimentos una
porción crucial de cereales como trigo
maíz o cebada del mundo están atrapadas
a causa de la guerra algo que también
pasa con los fertilizantes y a eso se le
suman los costes energéticos el
resultado es que se están disparando los
precios de los alimentos ahora los
economistas las organizaciones de ayuda
humanitaria y las autoridades
gubernamentales están advirtiendo sobre
las repercusiones más hambre en el mundo
una de las últimas en hacerlo ha sido
esta misma semana la secretaria del
tesoro estadounidense janet yellen que
advertía que está esta situación
conduciría a 10 millones de personas más
a la pobreza destaquemos algunas
portadas diario libération aquí en
francia crisis de alimentos la espada de
damocles dice el rotativo que la guerra
además de la destrucción en ucrania
puede producir grandes penurias en los
países dependientes de estas materias
primas diario la opinión analiza también
esta crisis alimentaria que viene afirma
que las de trigo maíz y aceite van a
repercutir en países pobres también
encontramos referencias a este asunto en
la prensa latina como este artículo en
latino titulado así trabaja en américa
latina para evitar crisis alimentaria
brasil dice el rotativo busca
posicionarse como abastecedor de maíz y
argentina aumenta retenciones para
controlar la inflación vamos a ver luego
cómo afecta esta situación américa
latina pero antes de nada estas son las
otras crisis digamos las crisis
derivadas no se saben si le parece que
hemos hablado mucho de la energética
porque afecta aquí a europa pero parece
que préstamos menos atención a los
alimentos porque afecta a países mucho
más pobres sí es cierto que desde europa
tenemos el tema pendiente de la crisis
energética y por qué nos toca porque es
rusia es el segundo exportador de crudo
del mundo y europa de presentase s el 60
por ciento de sus clientes con el gas el
carbón
y el crudo de petróleo sin embargo vamos
a empezar hablando ahora más y más de la
crisis alimentaria porque realmente
también eso puede tener consecuencias
para europa con flujos de migración muy
importantes a causa de la hambruna de
las hambrunas posibles y además tenemos
otro aspecto que nos distancia un poco
más de la crisis alimentaria de momento
es que tenemos esa política agrícola
europea la parte que hasta ahora nos
protege con excedentes pero eso no nos
protege para mucho tiempo ni para el año
que viene por ejemplo yo cómo lo ve
parece que hemos hablado mucho de esa
crisis energética y no tanto de ésta
sino además añadiendo a lo que decía
sabin efectivamente para nosotros desde
el punto de vista humanitario y sobre
todo pensando en aquellas crisis donde
la tensión es más altas y ahora mismo
pensando en el sahel central en el
cuerno de áfrica en oriente medio ya
estábamos en una situación
para torio de una crisis alimentaria de
los últimos 23 años en la región de
sahel central hemos multiplicado por
tres el número de millones de personas
en inseguridad alimentaria ya estamos
preparándonos debido a los efectos del
cambio climático después de temporadas
de gran sequía en países como somalia
como eritrea a una situación alimentaria
terrible después de dos años de kobe el
acceso y el transporte ya era más
complicado y entonces la crisis ucrania
efectivamente viene a añadirse a una
situación que ya era terriblemente
complicada una crisis que efectivamente
como lo señalaba antes ucrania y rusia
suponen el 30 por ciento del trigo
mundial en algunos países justamente ya
en situación de alta tensión que supone
incluso a veces la totalidad estoy
pensando en eritrea estoy pensando en
etiopía son países que importan
muchísimo entonces desde el punto de
vista
con su dependencia al trigo
hay una estimación de un total de 44
países afectados por la paralización del
llamado granero de europa pero entre
ellos hay que destacar algunas
situaciones de países muy pobres y otros
con conflictos internos a los que no
prestamos tanta atención me imagino que
son estos que estamos nombrando sobre
todo de áfrica y
antes mencionábamos en antes de entrar
en directo que estábamos mencionando el
caso del yemen es un caso que es
tremendamente llamativo ahí es donde
está una situación muy crítica
frente a la hambruna de millones de
personas y como eso puede tener
consecuencias más graves aún con la
crisis alimentaria de ahora vamos a
conectar con verdú solano investigador
en ciencias económicas y expertos en
medioambiente de la universidad de parís
es de la guerra en ucrania ha golpeado a
los mercados energéticos del mundo ahora
el planeta enfrenta una crisis más
profunda como decíamos la de la escasez
de alimentos y le pregunto señor durán
cómo se relacionan ambas crisis la
energética y la de los alimentos es
relevante mencionar el mecanismo de
transmisión
justamente doble defectos del conflicto
y las sanciones que ha impuesto rusia
sobre algunos países lo que genera un
shock sobre el suministro energía de
petróleo alimentos e insumos agrícolas
por ciento por lo tanto el gas es mal en
una materia prima es crucial para la
producción de electricidad y además una
fuente energía fundamental en varios
procesos industriales
en el caso del petróleo es más fácil
encontrar otros proveedores pero esto
depende justamente de la geopolítica del
conflicto y estas sanciones también
afectan alimentos y sabemos cumpleaños
rusias son importantes productores del
trigo maíz y aceite de girasol y según
datos de la fao cerca del 45 por ciento
de la producción de trigo mundial se
concentra en sucre ni rusia por lo tanto
el resultado del embargo económico sobre
rusos y de los rusos podría en
consecuencia disminuir la producción de
elementos y encarecer los productos y
generar más inflación si vamos a un país
de latinoamérica por ejemplo brasil la
cosecha del verano en septiembre de
octubre aún no tienen suficientes
fertilizantes y sin fertilizantes en
informar las autoridades
en forma de vida que los precios de los
alimentos siguen aumentando los próximos
meses
claro como decía el señor tú sola ni el
embargo a rusia afecta también a
latinoamérica por la falta de llegada de
fertilizantes a brasil por ejemplo
como lo comentaba el señor brasil por
ejemplo depende a 80 por ciento de los
fertilizantes gruesos y a pesar de que
brasil se considera como una alternativa
y puede una alternativa a rusia y
ucrania por los granos para cultivar
también tiene muchas limitaciones en
realidad con los los problemas
climáticos el fenómeno la niña que se
puede alargar y sobre todo es esa
cuestión de producción de fertilizantes
que hasta la fecha no existe realmente
en brasil y que quieren implementar
ahora luego están argentina también el
caso de argentina que también podría
transformarse en un gran abastece de
gelatina ya es uno de los mayores
exportadores y productores de soja de
maíz de trigo de granos y sin embargo
argentina tiene un problema inmenso de
inflación claro que está ahora a más de
50 por ciento a un aumento de más de 50
por ciento y eso llevó el al gobierno a
implementar
limitaciones a las exportaciones que
vienen de trigo
precisamente y también para crear como
una bolsa de
estabilización del precio del trigo como
para luchar contra la especulación sobre
los precios del trigo y para contener la
inflación interna y también una medida
para proteger las reservas internas de
trigo y además el problema de argentina
como lo mencionaba
es que ha vendido ya la cosecha de este
año está a 95 por ciento ya vendida así
que no hay mucho de sobra no hay mucho
margen de maniobra las primeras
estimaciones sugieren que al menos 10
millones de personas más podrían verse
empujadas a la pobreza sólo por el
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
lo ha dicho esta misma semana la
secretaria del pesado estadounidense
janet yellen que se puede hacer ante
ello yo yo creo que ya ha empezado a me
estaba haciendo reflexionar justamente
sobre sobre varios de los elementos que
podemos poner encima de la mesa y sobre
todo desde nuestra posición como
organización humanitaria pedir a los
países que más pueden hacer estamos
hablando de la primera voluntad política
si al final hay una cuestión también
casi de reflexión general a proponer no
es una cuestión muchas veces de
producción de abastecimiento en sí es
una cuestión a veces de acceso en los
espacios donde nosotros trabajamos por
ejemplo es la limitante de un aumento
del precio pensar que en países
muchísimo más pobres que francia la
cesta la compra puede costar 23 veces
más es para darnos una idea pensar que
por ejemplo antes comentó yemen hay una
crisis del carburante muy fuerte desde
hace años mucho antes de que la cuestión
ucraniana estuviera encima de la mesa y
eso nos preocupa porque eso es limitar
el acceso humanitario a personas que
están hoy en día en situaciones
extraordinariamente complejas entonces
desde luego permitir un acceso de las
poblaciones y países en situación más
difícil a los stocks que puede haber
alimenticios en el mundo y asegurarse de
que la especulación no avanza y de que
estamos hablando de alimentación en
zonas de inseguridad alimentaria y sobre
todo apelar otra vez a los países que
más pueden a que financien a la altura
de las necesidades todas las respuestas
humanitarias es decir por poner un
ejemplo en los países del sahel donde
nosotros trabajamos a veces los planes
de respuesta llegan a altura de 40 a 45%
estás hablando de que hay millones de
personas que están en necesidad que se
quedan fuera del plan entonces
el programa alimentario mundial de la
onu
está alertando sobre las dificultades
para financiar esa crisis alimentaria
porque ya no tienen el presupuesto para
tener una respuesta adecuada y
apelan también precisamente a aumentar
el presupuesto fíjense que la señora
helen sugirió esta misma semana que los
prestamistas con sede en washington
podrían proporcionar ayuda a las
personas vulnerables impulsar
inversiones en la agricultura y ordenar
las cadenas de suministro para abordar
las necesidades críticas como los
fertilizantes es decir hablar en el
fondo de acuerdos gubernamentales de
voluntad política porque ordenar esas
cadenas de suministro podrían paliar
bastante la situación que en la
actualidad en cambio si estos ciudades
que van a tomar mucho tiempo de momento
no tenemos respuesta inmediata a esa la
escasez del trigo de los granos en
general
y bueno hay una iniciativa que yo bueno
me di cuenta
de los organismos internacionales como
yo mencionaba pero también de la de la
web de la unión europea que está que se
está trabajando no está llevada a cabo
hasta ahora pero es una iniciativa bajo
propuesta de francia para crear ayudar a
los países que están muy dependientes
del trigo como egipto en los países
mediterráneos
y también en el norte de áfrica y para
ayudarles precisamente a implementar más
políticas agrícolas más y bueno es un
esfuerzo de solidaridad pero también de
apoyo a largo plazo voy a hacer en este
punto una breve pausa pero enseguida
volvemos hablando de la crisis de los
alimentos aquí en primera plana está
ahora
[Música]
la guerra está a las puertas de europa y
recuerda horas sombrillas de histeria la
comunidad se organizado para darles ropa
france24 está pendiente de los
acontecimientos en ucrania
con nuestros equipos en el terreno y
desde nuestros estudios lo mantenemos al
tanto
siga informado siga al día
liberté égalité actual y t
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
miles de personas cada año se ven
ubicadas al éxodo a huir de sus países
en busca de una vida mejor llevamos una
mirada humana a la migración masiva en
américa latina y en el resto del mundo
[Música]
acompáñenme inmigrantes por france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]
france24 su ventana al mundo
liberté égalité actual y ti
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de la crisis de alimentos
derivada de la guerra de ucrania lo
hacemos con jon cerezo responsable de
campañas humanitarias de oxfam
jean-pierre de uso lan investigador en
ciencias económicas y expertos en
medioambiente en la universidad de parís
este y sabrina nada grande adam
periodista independiente especializado
en latinoamérica que nos estaba hablando
precisamente justo antes de ir a la
pausa de un proyecto francés
un proyecto bajo una propuesta francesa
pero sobre buen don de la unión europeo
que se está trabajando ahora que está
apelando a más miembros de la unión
europea a juntarse y si el programa se
llama fund y se trataría de tres puntos
un apoyo que bueno para mí el más
importante apoyo a implementar políticas
agrícolas más más evidentes en el cono
norte de áfrica
en los países mediterráneos y también en
áfrica en el continente apoyo al
desarrollo con programas de
implementación de fertilizantes de
granos
enseguida para el corto plazo sería una
ayuda solidaria con granos
con los excedentes europeos y también es
el otro punto sería más
formación y cooperación intra regional a
ese nivel de el mediterráneo por ejemplo
jean-pierre tu sola una proporción
crucial del trigo el maíz y de la cebada
del mundo está atrapada en rusia y en
ucrania causa de la guerra y también una
buena porción de fertilizantes como
comentábamos antes del mundo que está
atascada creo que en el caso de los
fertilizantes de rusia y bielorrusia a
quién afecta más estos atascos y qué
consecuencias tienen
justamente para responder su pregunta y
podemos ir a un artículo escrito en el
2014 por un investigador peter harling
del instituto de estudios económicos
internacionales quien me dio justamente
el impacto que produjo en el país
europeo la crisis de anexión de ucrania
rusia justamente en el año mencionado y
su estudio dice que sobre una
disminución del 8% del pib en ucrania y
del 1% de justamente pib le ruso entre
el año 2014 y 2016 pero también se
produjo una disminución en valor y
afectó a los países europa dependiendo
justamente de la exposición de y de la
duración del conflicto a la época de la
anexión de la línea ahora bien si vamos
a latinoamérica aunque el volumen de
negocios claramente rusia es bajo en
comparación con otras regiones del mundo
en ciertos sectores productivos que se
están viendo afectados por la guerra
como los productores deben en el ecuador
la carne colombiana y los importadores
del fertilizante brasilero que lo
utilizan para la producción de la soya
en este sentido también brasil importa
cerca del 80% de los fertilizantes que
utilizan los agricultores y el 20 por
ciento de ese volumen proviene de rusia
su principal proveedor
las capacidades portadoras recursos se
ven afectadas por las sanciones con el
que juntamente dividendo occidente al
igual que ocurre con su vecina
bielorrusa otro gran perdedor de
fertilizante durante justamente este
período de guerra por lo tanto queda
mucho que s al respecto
y luego está me imagino que desde las
organizaciones humanitarias jon estoy
tratando mucho el tema las tres
superpuestas es decir veníamos de la
crisis del cobi y ahora tenemos esta y
luego sobre todo países que están en
permanente bucle de crisis de los países
que por ejemplo conflictos prolongados
hablamos antes de yemen también siria
sudán del sur y etiopía que ya estaban
enfrentando graves emergencias
alimentarias
lakovic y ahora esto me imagino que
tendréis detectados países que estén al
borde del colapso si totalmente en fin
me permite la expresión de llueve sobre
mojado si para muchas poblaciones al
final esto es una crisis más una nueva
crisis no por ello deja de ser
evidentemente muy fuerte y tiene un
impacto terrible sobre la población pero
haciendo un poco una perspectiva
mínimamente histórica efectivamente
estamos hablando de países que ya están
en una situación terriblemente
complicada
mencionaba antes en los últimos 23 años
multiplicado por tres la población en el
sahel central en situación de seguridad
alimentaria yemen siete años de guerra y
no me quiero marchar aquí como
humanitarios sin mencionar que al fin y
al cabo y al final del día los mapas del
conflicto y de la inseguridad se
superponen hoy en día el conflicto la
guerra sigue siendo el principal motor
para la inseguridad alimentaria al final
el carburante el pecio de carburante se
suma al final el kobe de sus
restricciones de acceso se suman estos
efectivamente hay países a los que
realmente tenemos que mirar mencionabas
al principio la diferencia de atención a
nosotros nos preocupan la diferencia
atención política la diferencia de
atención desde el financiero desde la
financiación al final hay una cuestión
mediática pero nosotros a los países
la mediática de la política una vez que
los medios dan el paso los políticos
y la sociedad también al fin y al cabo
son vasos comunicantes totalmente pero
lo que sí que le podemos pedir más a los
gobiernos es que sean más coherentes con
los acuerdos internacionales más
coherentes con las necesidades que están
expresadas claramente en todos los
programas de humanitaria estamos mención
antes el programa un dial de alimentos
que hizo ya un llamado una llamada a
todos los gobiernos ricos avisando de
que ésta ya tendría un impacto
rápidamente sobre el precio y la
capacidad de abastecer en alimentos a
poblaciones ya en estrés alimenticio
entonces necesitamos que efectivamente
la atención esté puesta
en esos países que llevan una
trayectoria de gran dificultad y de
inseguridad alimentaria los economistas
esperan que la guerra infle aún más los
precios de los alimentos la inflación a
medio y largo plazo no sólo tiene
consecuencias para los bolsillos sino y
pasó a un punto más político en sabin
sino que hemos visto también que en la
historia hay escenarios hiper
inflacionistas que han emergido
populismos y oscurantismos muy
preocupantes y por supuesto y también
otras
otras consecuencias que son medidas por
los tenistas como se les que se puede
entender como en el ejemplo en el caso
de argentina ahora con la inflación que
tiene desde ya años pero también en
venezuela por ejemplo
medidas de restricción de las
de la economía a la abertura mundial
pero al cine al cabo
los productores como brasil y argentina
yo creo que por el interés que tienen en
el aporte de divisas que eso les puede
traer van a considerar un aumento enorme
de su producción pero eso no se da este
año sino el año que viene quizás no se
sabe depende de los factores que hemos
evaluado como las condiciones climáticas
a mí lo que me preocupa también es
además de esa inflación y de la de las
reacciones quizás proteccionistas de
algunos países es que por ejemplo en
brasil bolsonaro considera como muy
oportuno una buena oportunidad de poder
cultivar más porque eso le aporta
como se dice agua a su molino de
cultivar y deforestar mucho más en
amazonía
de eso no hemos hablado pero yo creo que
es un tema pendiente para los años que
vienen bueno a pesar de que podemos ver
si evolucionado o se queda o no pero a
pesar de este problema los impactos
ambientales de esa crisis alimentaria
van a ser muy fuertes hay otros
obstáculos hay otros obstáculos además
naciones unidas estimó que hasta un 30
por ciento de las tierras de cultivo
ucranianas podrían convertirse en zonas
de guerra y debido a que millones de
ucranianos están huyendo del país o
sumándose al frente de batalla hay mucha
menos gente que pueda trabajar el campo
además no sé si hablamos de un problema
que tardará en solucionarse por completo
años teniendo en cuenta estos factores
decir además de que estamos en un
granero incluso cuando la situación está
pacificada no se habrá resuelto todavía
este problema de además yo creo que hay
que recordar también la situación en
ucrania nosotros nos permite el estar
presentes en polonia a ver un poco qué
es lo que está sucediendo
hablábamos antes de cifras es un poco
complicado programas de más de 5
millones de refugiados es una barbaridad
que llevamos más de 12 15 millones de
personas dentro del país que están ya en
situación de emergencia antes
desgraciadamente las elecciones nos
dicen que los conflictos pueden tardar
poco en empezar mucho en solucionarse o
en
disminuir su impacto en cualquier caso
toda la ayuda tiene que movilizarse de
hecho se acoge con buena perspectiva en
la directiva temporal de protección de
la unión europea que permite que todos
los ucranianos sean refugiados en el
momento de llegar hace falta extenderla
y hace falta efectivamente rápidamente
movilizarse para esas zonas que van a
verse afectadas pero efectivamente como
en todo conflicto nuestra posición no
puede ser otra
cs de las armas que se abran diálogos
que se abra la paz y que se permita el
acceso sin ningún tipo de restricción a
los actores humanitarios es verdad esa
frase que facil es algo que rápido se
comienzo un conflicto y lo que tarda
luego en cicatrizar se los señores son
los precios de los alimentos los
fertilizantes el petróleo el gas e
incluso los metales como el aluminio o
el níquel también los costes del
transporte el desastre de esta crisis de
alimentos por el descubierto las
consecuencias de una en un escenario de
globalización y de interconexión total
de toda la economía
es evidente que existen caderas del
fruto que están siendo afectadas pero
más allá de eso la pregunta es qué tan
rápido puede adaptarse la oferta a la
demanda existente por alimentos insumos
utilizando este concepto de
globalización para evitar justamente el
aumento del peso de consumo a causa de
la demanda está velocidad de adaptación
dependerá justamente de las
coordinaciones políticas que están
haciendo en todo el mundo un proyecto
son justamente es las acciones tomadas
por los ministros de agricultura de las
américas en una reunión reciente de la
oea y también parte de estas acciones
pueden tratar de reducir los defectos de
los altos y buscar una salida en el
sector agrícola por ejemplo en brasil se
realizó una disminución de cerca de 34
por ciento del flete marítimo una parte
del frente teniendo en cuenta que una
parte importante de los insumos
importados por brasil aprovechó
justamente esta interconexión global de
toda la economía
desde hace tiempo además el aumento de
los precios de los alimentos hace un
catalizador de revueltas sociales y
políticas en países pobres árabes
africanos y muchos de ellos subsidian
alimentos básicos como el pan para
evitar este tipo de problemas creen que
pueden existir estallidos de este tipo a
partir de la guerra en ucrania a partir
de ahora
y ciertamente
se pueden producir levantamientos como
en el 2010 y una incluso una nueva
primavera árabe como se produjo
en esa época y yo temo de que eso ocurra
porque cuando vemos que egipto por
ejemplo con 100 millones de habitantes
como ya decimos
esta dependiente al 60 por ciento del
trigo ruso y ucrania nos podemos
preguntar cómo van a ser como a pesar de
la solidaridad internacional de
programas de apoyo y todo lo que sea no
podemos resolver y compensar
rápidamente la ausencia de cosechas de
ucrania ahora así que es una amenaza muy
grande si éstas viven sociales yo creo
que permitidme que me repita un poco
pero efectivamente son factores que se
retroalimentan en cierto sentido donde
hay conflicto hay una falta de acceso
hay una falta que es humanitaria y una
falta de acceso de las poblaciones en
necesidad a esa ayuda humanitaria suele
haber un aumento del precio de
carburante y eso al mismo tiempo produce
mayor tensión son factores que desde
luego van de la mano uno del otro
muchísimas gracias a los tres por
habernos acompañado hoy me quedo ya sin
más tiempo y a todos ustedes les
esperamos la próxima semana que en
primera plana gracias
[Música]